sprechen wir über diesen wirklich
seltsamen fall eine frau 23 jahre alt im
auto die eigene mutter seit jahres ist
meine tochter und freunde legen blumen
nieder hier und dann kommt heraus die
tote ist garnicht shaban k das ist
wirklich ein mordfall mit filmreifen
wendungen in einem auto in ingolstadt da
saß eine doppelgängerin die jetzt tot
ist ja da müssen wir noch mal liegt denn
dieses wirre dunkel bringen dort dieses
spektakulären mordfall in ingolstadt
bild reporter jörg völkerling ist für
uns dort mitten in ingolstadt wird eine
frau getötet die eltern wein um ihre
tochter ein hoppala ist nicht die
tochter ist eine ganz andere frau und
die frau von der man dachte sie lebt
sitzt jetzt sie ist tot lebt und sitzt
jetzt im knast schilder uns was sind die
hintergründe die du dir im moment
zusammenbastelt dort in diesen wirren
mordfall
ja basteln ist wahrscheinlich das
richtige stichwort das wird auch die
kripo ingolstadt im moment mit allen
mühen und allen kräften versuchen und
ich muss ehrlich sagen in 20 jahren die
ich für bild über verbrechen berichte
ist meine solche konstellation noch
nicht untergekommen wir stehen jetzt
hier an dem ort wo blumen und fotos von
dem wirklichen opfer niedergelegt worden
sind es handelt sich um khadija eine 23
jahre alte
algerierin die er aus heilbronn
ursprünglich stammt aber mit einem
rapper hier aus ingolstadt in einer
beziehung war und jetzt wird das
wirklich etwas kompliziert und man muss
sehr langsam zum mitschreiben darüber
reden die
fahrbahn
die zunächst für tot gehalten wurde die
von ihren eltern in dem auto mutmaßlich
aufgefunden wurde am vergangenen
dienstagabend
war offenbar hatte ein auge geworfen auf
den freund von katja und hat und soll
dass es der momentane stand der
ermittlungen dann ein freund von ihr
einen ebenfalls 23-jährigen
kosovo-albaner schick hier
sollte ihn gebeten haben du die katja
die redet schlecht über mich die benimmt
sich wie eine [ __ ] so wurde uns das hier
geschildert die muss weg die muss
verschwinden und dann soll also dieser
kosovo albaner mit
unzähligen messerstichen mit schlagring
also er sollte wirklich auf diese frau
eingewirkt haben sie muss ganz
entsetzlich entstellt gewesen seien und
ob er wirklich wusste dass sozusagen er
damit den weg frei machen soll für
sarah bahn auf die er wohl selber auch
ein auge geworfen hatte wo er wohl
selber auch gefühle entwickelt hatte das
weiß man im moment noch nicht man weiß
durch die obduktion am mittwoch ist dann
die wahre identität der leiche in diesem
mercedes der hier wirklich nur zwei
meter von mir stand ans licht gekommen
sarah bahn wurde in ingolstadt
festgenommen und sie belastete dann den
kosovo albaner sehr schwer der wirklich
nur 200 meter vom tatort oder vom
fundort der leiche muss man sagen man
weiß noch nicht wo der tatort ist 200
meter entfernt in einem blog wohnte und
dann kam das sek mitten in der nacht um
3 und hat seine wohnungstür aufgesprengt
er wohnte damit seinem bruder und seiner
mutter ein lackierer hat man uns erzählt
und die sprengung war so heftig dass es
sogar die nachbarswohnung noch die tür
eingerissen hat und jetzt sitzen beide
in untersuchungshaft und der kripo
obliegt dass dieses motto rätsel
letztlich wirklich aufzudröseln und die
wahren hintergründe aufzudecken
was deutet im moment darauf hin wer
tatsächlich das messer in der hand
gehalten hat also wer tatsächlich die
more den mord begangen hat
also aus der konstellation und aus der
kommunikation der polizei ingolstadt
lässt sich herauslesen dass die shaban
den kosovo albaner sehr schwer belastet
dass er sozusagen ausführendes werkzeug
gewesen sein soll wir haben aber auch
gehört dass auch shaban eine sehr
psychisch auffällige persönlichkeit
offenbar gewesen ist sie hat er sich
kurz vorher von ihrem partner getrennt
mit dem sie von ihrem mann mit dem sie
nach jesidischen recht verheiratet war
und
auch der mann der
in der ermittlung keine rolle spielt
aber natürlich für das vorleben von
shaban sehr wichtig ist hat sich
offenbar in den wochen vor dem mord an
khadija sehr stark bedroht gefühlt er
hat seinem vermieter gesagt er hat ein
friseurgeschäft in einem dorf außerhalb
von ingolstadt und hat ihm gesagt bitte
hier ab und zu mal patrouille ich fühle
mich nicht mehr sicher er hat wohl um
sein leben gefürchtet und
jetzt ist er untergetaucht er ist nicht
in seiner wohnung er ist nicht in dem
friseursalon
er hat offenbar immer noch angst dass
irgendetwas vor sich geht und es ist ja
auch immer noch sehr mysteriös und zu
hinterfragen warum die eltern von sarah
bahn an dem abend so zielgerichtet hier
in dieser straße nach ingolstadt
gefahren sind und warum sie dann
sozusagen diese leiche aufgefunden haben
all das sind auch noch fragen die offen
sind die die ermittlungen noch lösen
müssen
ein mordfall mit noch vielen offenen
fragen
die neuesten erkenntnisse dazu hat jörg
völkerling schon zusammengefasst vielen
herzlichen dank dir
[Musik]